motorcycle Caravans are the Prelude to
his public appearances
[Music]
they're followed by supporters cries of
Mito or Legend the minute they see
President Jade bolsonaro his middle name
is Messiah and he believes God has
chosen him to lead Brazil his fans think
he has a different sort of superpower
I'm a lawyer but I'm wearing a Batman
costume because I see bolsonaro as a
superhero without a cape a guy who
fights an entire system defender of
family values against abortion
Jade bolsonaro was born here in the
state of Sao Paulo to a family of humble
means he loved weapons and joined the
army but was expelled for bad behavior
he then became a congressman for an
obscure right-wing party but after seven
four-year terms he began to stand out
and he made his career basically using
this bad behavior as an instrument to
become famous he's the one who say
things that no one has the courage to
say
for example the criminals should be shot
on site that he'd rather his son die in
a car accident than be gay he's seen as
a racist and suggests A Woman's Place is
in the home during former president
jilma rousseff's impeachment session he
dedicated his vote to the officer who
tortured her during Brazil's military
dictatorship
just
a destination of the devil supporters
have an almost religious adoration for
the president a combination of hard-line
conservative values and nationalism have
convinced millions of Brazilians that he
is the only man who could save this
country from what people like these
regard as communism
since becoming president he's loosened
gun laws even though 70 of Brazilians
oppose the move he's expanded
Agricultural and Mining Frontiers in the
Amazon rainforest
and when Brazil's death toll from
covid-19 became the second highest in
the world he showed little compassion
insisting people go back to work even
before there was a vaccine
I am sorry for the dead I am sorry but
we are all going to die one day we have
to stop being a country of CC's
been compared to Donald Trump whom he
greatly admires both are charismatic and
anti-political establishment both show
disregard for Democratic institutions
like the Supreme Court in Congress and
like Trump bolsonaro's intolerance and
sensitivity to the needs of the poor and
his handling with a pandemic could make
his first presidential term his last
Sao Paulo
[Applause]